[Applauso]
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi ciao il libro sia portato
qua in questa foresta chissà quale sarà
la creatura che vive qua
[Musica]
siamo nel posto giusto
il primo punto
siamo nel posto giusto si quindi la
creatura vive realmente quale la foresta
qualche voce nei commenti secondo voi
che cos'è la creatura e mi raccomando
lasciate un mi piace qui sotto e ora
mandiamolo ricerca della creatura
sperando che non ci brani
tutto secco qua che cosa sono successo e
forse dobbiamo cercare delle orme delle
impronte della creatura il libro indica
di la primavera di qua andiamo qui porta
c'è una forma gigante ogni passo fatto
dalla creatura corrisponde a un fosso
quindi oltre a essere gigante e anche
molto pesante e in più sta andando in
questa direzione quindi potrebbe essere
proprio la direzione giusta seguiamo la
cosa parliamo
guardo questo impronta e proprio fresca
vuol dire che la creatura è posta taqwa
recentemente si chiede teche grande e
anche lì c'era un'altra è lì lì un
elefante sembravano mi dissi misto le
orme di qua presto di qua
guarda la porta
una casetta ma che oggi vivono dentro la
creatura vivrà la dentro una creatura
così grande la dentro non lo so sembra
più una casetta normale magari c'è
qualcuno un contadino che vive là dentro
non lo so ci sono un modo per scoprirlo
dobbiamo andare gustare ii e vedere chi
si apre sì ma teniamoci pronti con il
libro staffette che il libro è anche uno
scudo contro le creature contro le cose
paurosi ci proteggerà allora io vado a
bussare e magari non lo so chiedo se
stanno provando qualcosa da mandare ora
dobbiamo chiederle informazioni sulla
creatura questa è la nostra passione le
informazioni sulla creatura è anche la
creatura dovrà mangiare no appunto
pagare la creatura vuole mangiare noi
non ci avevo pensato questo eyes
brighiamo c prima che faccia buio era
tutto più paura ok andiamo a chiedere
informazioni
busto io parli tu ok no guarda forse è
meglio se busso io e parli tu sai perché
magari potrebbe avermi con le mie
domande su cibi abusato e parlo io vabbè
poi io magari fosse la seconda domanda
non ti azzardare a chiedere del cibo mi
raccomando
ok ci provo non lo so non posso
promettere lo sai come sono io no
privati
[Musica]
c'è nessuno si sentono dei rumori dentro
sicuramente c'è qualcuno
senti stato un momento delle ventole
sicuramente stanno preparando da
mangiare oppure stanno mangiando
qualcuno
[Musica]
ecco vedi pd per fortuna adesso
chiediamo informazioni sulla creatura
forse non vuole proprio aprirci
stavamo in realtà cercando una creatura
lo so che è un po strano ma noi stiamo
cercando una creatura e possiamo entrare
in casa e chiedervi qualche informazione
guarda mi trovate proprio una giornata
sbagliata
la casa è molto disordinata io son da
sola e oggi non è proprio la giornata
giusta per far rientrare
ma c'è qualcuno c'è qualche creatura con
lei per caso
creatura ma adesso abbiamo visto anche
delle orme là fuori giganti
abbiamo pensato che magari qualche
creatura si aggirava qui intorno alla
casa mai sentito parlare richieste
intero alcuna dentro casa l'ho finita e
dai ma giusto cinque minuti
[Musica]
per questa volta facciamo rientrare il
ragazzo
gentile
sono delle domande
accomodate mi disse che lui la porta da
ibra su
una casa di campagna
[Musica]
forse dovremmo andarcene ma che pochi si
cambia una cassa di casa di aliano qua
accomodatevi accomodati
gli offro qualche cosina
volevamo farne un paio di domani che ci
sbrighiamo andiamo via perché buio
presto la notte quindi è meglio stesso
ma prima dobbiamo sbrigarci a e così da
e allora oggi offre una cosina che vi ri
cuore tu mi devi promettere li devi
promettere che preparerà i ai nostri
uffici che sono venuti a farci anche
domanda e che subito andranno via
micheli farai una tisana molto delicata
ma lasciate così e anche un po
energetica perché dovete vento partire
si
aspetti vogliono farci bere una tisana
un tenere qualcosa di strano e poi ha
detto qualcosa di quando cala la notte
che sostanza calando la notte e siamo in
mezzo al bosco soprattutto come faremo
ad uscirne da qui come faremo a tornare
a casa ha detto io cosa dobbiamo fare
secondo voi parlano tutti sono perché
pisano dobbiamo assolutamente sapere se
c'è una creatura qua quindi l'unico modo
per farsi dare le informazioni credo che
sia bene questa tipa da noi ci dobbiamo
sprecare dobbiamo assolutamente
chiedervi della creatura prende di punti
e andare via velocemente altrimenti se
non prendiamo tutti e dieci punti
si trasformerà in una creatura
abbiamo pochi minuti di tempo per
rispondere alle vostre domande poi li
dobbiamo mandare via cala presso la
notte si è messo benissimo che facciamo
tutti alla domanda che creatura tempo
perché abbiamo vinto dove i propri
lavori creatura quale creature avete
visto
che non ne avete visto
ma che dici sicuri se si parla di fronte
alla porta di casa sarà il bue di dj
francesco che viene ogni tanto non
lasciamo io non ho pure oppure oppure
qua vicino c'è una casa dove ci sono
tanti bambini che avevano giocare ogni
tanto fanno i dispetti e quindi creano
delle norme
poi tu esci peso loro intento e quello
che noi siamo la casa ci fa vendiamo
però ormai siamo abituati
e allora se non c'è nessuna creatura
quando ce ne andiamo andremo via andiamo
via togliamo il disturbo non ci dite
niente della creatura allora noi ce ne
andiamo
[Musica]
te lo dicono come dopo giorno quando
rivale andare via prima tenta di dire
quando dopo che beviamo una positiva
insieme siete venuti qua non quelli
infuso che preparato la settimana scorsa
che è conservato 9
no assolutamente
sei sicuro sui ricercatori questi come
me e capitolo ricercatore credo che
l'unica soluzione sia de relato in
strada altrimenti non ci dirà mai dove
la creatura però magari si chiama così
per ora prima che faccia poi mi servono
delle foglioline di più pisa che sono
giù in fondo al viale a destra in
prestiti etc estiva
riprende dicesti netto papa lo devi
promettere cioè dopo lo prometti melo
che non che non gli dai quell infuso lì
che abbiamo messo via papa guardami
negli occhi e prometti me lo
prometto non ti preoccupare
va bene mi ha convinto per di cestinato
vai è stata un pochettino di quei fiori
di bra ad ora per i cesti netto 15 so
niente
brava mi raccomando moltre mazzettino ok
va bene fare torno presto ciao
ma una domanda ci sono anche biscotti
sia messi anche i biscottini
ripescate che si scrive
di lei biscotti
a blocchi di bellezza che facciamo non
le facciamo investimenti liberista siamo
qui non ci dovrei abbinare di questo
signor lino perché ora qualcosa di
strano non lo vedi la rue supergentile
ci preme latisana ci offre pure i
biscotti e tutto fatto in casa tra
l'altro siamo che ci fidiamo di tale
ramo cercare la creatura sia meglio non
bere né mangiare niente io non ho mai
ragione la creatura da cerchiamo perugia
che siamo qua abbiamo uniamo l'utile al
dilettevole no biscotti latisana
le domande sulla creatura è perfetto
secondo voi cosa dovremmo fare dovremmo
bere latisana del signor lino oppure
dovremmo scappare da qua io non ho dubbi
su questo sicuramente dovrò bere e
mangiare prima di andare alla ricerca
fino si mangia si beve
e va bene speriamo almeno che dopo si
dia una risposta sulla creatura
eccoci qua
freddato
un'allergia a un antipatico non si sto
cercando con le erbe di di pura armani
adesso ti porto abusi biscotti i costi
grazie
ix20 che investito potendo è sì un
pochettino
svitato ma adesso percettive portato i
biscottini paura che stia nascondendo
qualcosa invece che cosa stanno
ascoltando sto guardando che quella di
sale così strano che mi
sembravano molto gentile questa allergia
che mi prende sempre
stoffa ti sto cercando una soluzione è
una vocalizzo che mi viene strano
mal di gola è sia un particolare viene
fuori
se prendo un
mediche gentile ha portato già latitante
risponde
questo è buonissimo con buoni
pur
lo sta sentendo qualcosa ecco tutto bene
tutto bene se mi prende sempre un po
così ma ho trovato quasi il di video
e video o particolare le buonissime e
non vi accomodate come usato come
cammino si state più comoda c'era
riavviciniamo le cose che leggo come
dante vi del divano
che avevi ragione un po svitato
cerchiamo di finire velocemente questa
tisana così potrà darci le informazioni
sulla gru
[Musica]
scusatevi beni di sbrigarmi
corato biscottini andrebbero dati
biscottino social feb
stato un po strana sarei anch'io
ci accomodiamo ci rilassiamo fatto emo
datevi tranquilli effetti
avversi strano questo posto anzi è molto
rilassante mi sappia sorgere pisolino
che mettete le tazzine la trascinano si
ok
dovete riposarsi biscotti
il biscotto iolite mondo animale sei tu
sei un prezzo molto vero ma anche
l'immagine bisogno
serve poi mangio io
[Musica]
sapendo di lingua o non puoi toccare
sono
un buono
ti prego no per passa in fretta io odio
le notti di luna piena le odio né
sopporto tutte le volte la stessa
questi romani e
chambery sassi ciao vi siete
addormentati
credo che ci siamo addormentati
no no non è strano el'atmosfera il posto
avete fatto una camminata sicuramente vi
siete stancati a camminare aspetta un
attimo e vino dove è il mio papà che si
trasforma si è trasformato in un ghigno
si si è andata a dormire perché era
molto molto molto molto stanco mi ha
detto di salutarvi e mi ha detto di
accompagnare dio alla porta
del avrebbe detto che avevo qualcosa di
strano questi ignori assai forti questi
motivi rubato cosa sono questi no è che
la casa è un pop e che quindi scrive o
la strada di legno ma vengono da lì
andiamo contro la prima di cronaca sono
scrivo così la chiama
il nostro cagnolino che fa che molto
vivace soprattutto la notte qui ma è
sempre gradito è un cagnolino un po
grande però è molto vivace e quindi lo
trova essere questa la creatura che
stiamo cercando un cagnolino che in
realtà è
mai visto un lupo mannaro in vita mia
mai mai mai ve lo posso giurare ragazzi
non ho mai detto lupo mannaro io ho solo
detto lupo infatti ci ha detto il pon a
naro nascondendo qualcosa d'altro no no
non siamo da laura
non potete aprire questa porta perché
non possiamo aprire questa porta perché
non si può perché non si può aprire
non vi posso far entrare guarda
più marzo
scorso è morta
no io lo sapevo che non volevo farvi
entrare adesso adesso ormai è troppo
tardi
mio padre ti ha morso è un lupo mannaro
sì ormai lo sapete diamo sa inutile che
conte che io continuo a tenere il
segreto
è importante chi viene morso da un lupo
mannaro e condannato a divenire un lupo
mannaro a sua volta lo sapevo e adesso
no
già c'è già sento che mi sta venendo
qualcuno a braccio mi sto trasformando
guarda certo il frontale di diane via di
canale via non possiamo ottenere di qua
dentro
no mai
[Musica]
assolutamente mandato via po morderà il
film sono i pericoli
ma io non voglio mandare proprio come lo
chiamavano via fu morderci così perfette
un sicuro nel bosco non voglio che però
da solo al buio di nota è un lupo
mannaro cosa vuoi che succeda
per me viva
bravi sia
io
funzionato un'idea ferma lì
speriamo che non torni più per tutta la
notte adesso